no new once november here's everything
that's wrong with america let's go
firstly for context my name's emma i
live in australia and i have degrees in
sociology and law okay stop for a second
one degree in sociology you're a
professional useless person two you're
in australia i don't want to hear about
your opinions on what's wrong with
america i don't give a
i really don't care like are you you're
busily locked down
like for the 900th consecutive day
on on an island like congratulations to
you why would i one of my favorite
things about the left is that they think
that i give any at all about what
foreigners think of the united states
like i do not care i do i could not care
less number one in a surprise to no one
what's wrong with america guns y'all are
obsessed with your right to bear arms
here's a concept
i don't give a sh
the feeling is mutual lady
why do i care about your feelings about
our right to bear arms guns i don't like
your guns well good you live in
australia stay there no one asked you